I know that you're a big star Wars fan
oh my god I'm such a big star Wars fan
and not and you know it's funny because
now our life before quarantine we look
back on it and it feels like a hundred
years ago you know but I know that just
before the quarantine wanted to like in
January you know pretty not that long
ago you went to what's it called
galaxy's edge the Star Wars experience
at Disneyland I we went it was our new
years my best friends and I heard like
New Year's celebration we went to
Disneyland and there two galaxies edge
and it I mean listen I as a child in
kindergarten refused to go about my name
and people had to call me Leia and I
found the two boys in the class that I
was friends with a cute one I made Han
Solo and the one that I didn't think was
that cute was Luke and could be my
brother and we just played Star Wars
every single day it was a part of my DNA
um so being that as an adult and
witnessing what they created at
Disneyland I mean this is this is fully
an unpaid advertisement you have to go
to Disneyland to witness galaxy's edge
if you like Star Wars you're promoting
Disneyland and galaxy's edge and you're
not getting paid to do it because for a
minute I thought okay usually when
someone's yelling at me go to Disneyland
it's because they're getting paid a
couple hundred thousand dollars but yeah
that's great but we have you posted some
footage of you at galaxy's edge I think
getting interrogated by a stormtrooper
we have something in common because when
I grew up I had everyone called me Leia
as well I really put the buns on your
head too yeah yeah that was very gender
confused but I for me she was the one I
could relate to the most and I'm curious
I mean now you're in this position as a
Star Wars fan where they're these the
Star Wars universe will never end they
keep making new new projects and new
characters do you ever think to yourself
wait a minute I might be able to be in
one of those and if so what would you be
what what kind of character would you
want to be I mean I would love it's
probably sounds crazy if the opportunity
to be a lead in the Star Wars film came
around listen I wouldn't say no um but I
also just think it'd be really cool to
be an extra I think it'd be very cool to
put on like a stormtrooper uniform and
show up to set all day and sit there for
12 hours doing the same walk back and
forth and just witnessing the magic
because there is there's something so
magical about the movies like that and
part of you know being an actor is you
see the inside of it and sometimes
that's great and other times it can take
some the magic away so I don't know that
I'd want to ruin the magic for myself
but that yeah you having youth you're
this big star you have a lot of clout
you love Star Wars and if you could be
any character you'd want to be an extra
running in the background with a helmet
on yes yeah do you remember the movie
hook you know how many people like we're
extras in that movie you just popped up
who her friends are like I love that I
think that's so cool and I don't know I
would I just I think if you neat just
tell my kids one day see that see that
storm sure that's me that was me they'll
never believe me but but you could also
show them movies where you hear this
star I mean this is true you're not
wrong but I just I don't know it's great
it's sweet I just find it really funny
[Laughter]